it's International women's day hooray
unfortunately it no longer means
anything the final victory of feminism
is erasing women as an entire category
they don't even exist anymore literally
it's kind of funny
women getting lectured by men about the
Pains of menstruation that's the final
victory of feminism well the Minnesota
judge called Patrick Diamond has just
ruled that USA powerlifting must allow
men to compete against women and as
you'd expect powerlifting groups you're
not warning this will effectively end
competitive powerlifting for women we
thought we would speak to a competitive
female powerlifter April Hutchinson
represents Team Canada she joins us
tonight April thank you and I'm sorry to
laugh this is actually a very sad story
and I'm just wondering how you feel
about it
well uh thank you for having me Tucker
um how are we feeling the women of
powerlifting are we're outraged we're
angry we're hurt we're offended we're
basically every emotion except for happy
I just don't I know you're not supposed
to criticize trans anybody but here's a
guy who's horning into your sport and
Wrecking it like I don't know why he has
to be a hero that's appalling who would
do something like that what's this guy's
problem do you think
um you know what I don't even know if
it's so much uh the person right it's
it's the policy so yeah at the end of
the day the policy is allowing him to
compete um you know what I feel good
about myself if I was a male taking
female records and accepting spots no
but
well that's it and and you're right
obviously it's a troubled person and I
don't want to be mean but I mean it's
just so awful to do that to you you're
brave enough to come on the show I'm
certain you'll be punished for it so you
must really mean it if you're willing to
do you know any other female power
lifters who support this
well that's the thing if I didn't do
anything about it I mean there was times
where I couldn't sleep at night I mean
I've been battling this for about two
years now finally women are coming out I
get daily emails and messages from women
saying thank you so much for standing up
for women in sports a lot of women are
silenced and feel silenced and that they
have no voice or they're afraid to speak
up a fear of maybe getting kicked out of
the Federation
um to be called names right for backlash
but no we're growing stronger and louder
and the amount of support is is
overwhelming actually
I have to just ask since you were a
woman having a man lecture you about
what it's like to be a female power
lifter is that empowering for you
no it's I I honestly I it's no it's it's
it's crazy and
um you know I I say this every day I
talk to my boyfriend about this and I
said I can't believe we're actually
having this debate and this conversation
in 2023 no the trans movement is the
ultimate mansplaining ever invented it's
just unbelievable April Hutchinson thank
you for coming on great to see you thank
you so much
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight